everyone was pretty keen for the second
movie to be bigger on every level this
film in particular I think will look
great on imax screens is the world so
big the sets are huge
because you don't have the set up and
you don't have to kind of explain the
world in the same way you have the
opportunity to to make these sequences
even richer we have a director that
really kind of works in in a visual way
the cinematography is stunning there's a
lot of aerial shots and I think any time
that you shoot a film and you show a
bird's eye perspective you really get a
broad scope
let's begin in my max it is going to be
amazing because it is so visually
stunning it's pretty interesting go
inside somebody's fears and to put it
for your simulation up there and to kind
of experience somebody's lucid dreaming
why not when you have this world set up
for you but it's so hyper real why not
kind of use that to make it more epic in
imax they almost feel like it's a ride
expect a lot of heart pumping scenarios
there's a lot of suspense in this movie
seeing it in imax allows you to kind of
experience that kind of unique way final
every last one of them I like to feel
the movie and when you go to an imax
theater that's what you do you feel like
you're a part of the action that's the
only way to see a movie like this
you